من الكويت ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف الفنان
طارق العلي طارق صبحك الله بالخير يعني
اعزائنا للشعب الكويتي
لكل محبي الفنان عبد الكريم عبد القادر
اليوم لما الناس تعرف الكويت تقول والله
الابراج عبد الكريم عبد القادر وغيره من
الامور اذا هو داله على الكويت بهذا الصوت
هذه هذه الميزه اللي يكسبها فنان بانه
يكون وجه لبلاده ما الذي يعني
السلام عليكم صبحكم الله بالخير
وعظم الله اجرنا واجركم وكل محب لهذا
الفنان الكبير عبد الكريم عبد القادر نسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى اللهم امين الله يرحمه
ويغفر له ويسكنه فسيح جناته ويلهم اهله
الصبر والسلوان
الحقيقه يعني اسم مثل عبد الكريم عبد
القادر مثل ما تفضلوا كثير من الاسماء
الكبيره الفنانين والفنانات في مجال بناء
حتى في مجال في كل مجال عبد الكريم
يتذكرني في توفى عمي عبد الحليم عبد الرضا
الكل اجمع على محبته
ويتغنى باعماله الفنيه الجميله ايضا عبد
الكريم عبد القادر من الاسماء الكبيره
الكويتيه الوطنيه اللي نتذكر دائما وطني
النهار هذا النهار الجليل اللي تغنى فيه
دوله الكويت
عبد الكريم عبد القادر
بفضل الله الصنع اللي هذا الاسم
احترام كبير محبه كبيره وارتبط فيه الصغير
والكبير هو ارتبط فيه حتى في مشاعرك انسان
على اليوم لما اسمع عبد الكريم عبد القادر
اعيش مع الحاله اللي يغنيها واتذكر حتى
حياتي الخاصه المشاعر
الرياضه اليوم انا كرياضي متعصب اذا كان
بيامن العاصمه نتذكر بسم الله
وبدايه السماد
الاغاني الوطنيه
والاجتماعيه
له بصمه في كل مجال وفي وجدان يعني كل
كويتي وخليجي حتى لو كان مهتم بشتى وعربي
طبعا بشتى المجالات
الجميع اجمع على قديش كان احساسه مرهف
وقديه كان رومانسي اللافت بالنسبه الي انه
استطاع انه يحافظ على هذا هاي الرومانسيه
وهذه الحساسيه على مدى عقود طويله يعني ما
كانت مرتبطه بسن شبابه مثلا او بحاله هو
كان بيمر فيها ولكن مرتبطه بروحه وبشخصيته
هو كانسان
شوفوا طال عمرك
الزمن اللي هم عاشوا فيه ايضا
زمن الكلمه
حتى الان في كلمات جميله
واسماء كريمه كبيره تغني في في عصرنا لكن
جيلهم جيل المعاناه جيلهم جيل صعب انك
حتى تقرا اسرتك انك تغني ولا ايضا جيل عاش
المشاعر الاشياء يعني
ايضا الجيل الانسان الخلوق ولا انتم كلكم
ما عليك زود ابو محمد
ابو محمد طارق يعني انا بودي اسال انا شفت
لك فيديو بالطياره مع عبد الكريم عبد
القادر في اغنيه ما نسينا وقاعد يبتسم
وانت تغنيها معاه كلمني عن هذا الانسان
شلون كان انا ادري لكن كلم المشاهد اليوم
اللي ما يعرفه
عبد الكريم عبد القادر
شابك يعرفك الابتسامه
فانا دائما اضحك طبعا ايضا اصدقائي
الخاصين استاذ خالد
27 سنه صديق لك هذا الشاب
الكويتي ايضا صديقه واحنا خاصه
الكريمه فلما شفته بالطياره قعدت انا
دايما احب امزح معاهم الكبار هذين في دعوه
كريمه من معالم المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
وفي مناسبه من المناسبات في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الغالي على قلوبنا حفظه
الله حب خليجنا ان شاء الله الامه العربيه
كلها
فقاعد اقول حق خالد
فهو يضحك انا طبعا انتم عارفين كراسي
الطيران
قاعد اقول انا احب واحد
يكون جنب بعض وهو يضحك يقول وانا احبك
وانا
يا حبيب عمري
هذي كلمه ايه
طارق العلي شكرا جزيلا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات